what do you feel more relaxed if you had
a puppy right now
yeah
shut your mouth
shut up
[Music]
oh this is nice isn't it
make sure you're in a comfortable
position
would you feel more relaxed if you had a
dressing gown
yeah oh
I'm taking that home
that's good look at this
that is your personalized dressing thank
you yes I do feel more relaxed that's
great it's nice and warm too
is there a room in your house that you
would describe as yourself
they're the bedroom
you're in that room
it's a Sunday morning what's the song or
album you're playing
rumors Fleetwood Mac
oh fantastic it's a real Sunday morning
album that one
any song on it dreams
lunch time comes you head to the pub for
a roast what are you drinking find the
Guinness
would you feel more relaxed if you had a
point of Guinness yeah
it's brilliant
I can see who I love Bible do so well
you're real people Pleasers
oh would you look at this
oh I don't care that it's 11 o'clock or
whatever it is
do you prefer to Holiday in the
scorching Heat or the frozen snow
scorching heat do you turn of course not
this color generally
Casper's cousin
what's your favorite season summer can't
be it what's your favorite sound
it's a good question
I like I sleep to Green noise on Spotify
you know all these different colored
noises they have these days it's very
like
sounds like airplanes
yeah it's nice what's your favorite
smell
petrol
hahaha
what happens I finish this
which book would you choose to relax I'm
so sorry I'm actually gonna have to move
because my my legs have started to not
feel anything
you know what's funny you think that
that's not making it into the edit
[Laughter]
yes I would I actually just bought one
of these on Amazon
funny you should say that it's also from
Amazon
thank you
I love this it doesn't have the same
effect if you do do you have anyone that
could do this
okay okay how's the thanks how's the
pace it's good were you expected this
when you came to work today no but we'll
roll with it yeah we'll roll with it
very relaxed what type of surface makes
the hairs on your body go fuzzy
a metal head massager from Amazon
what word makes you smile from ear to
ear
I can't say it uh I don't know this is
getting weird though
yes please
I'm not relaxing I'm all of a sudden I'm
all of a sudden not relaxed
I'm well aware I'm well aware
thanks for that that was nice guys it's
relaxing yeah yeah everyone's up
laughing this is serious stuff please
should toilet paper hang over or under
I've been
testing that theory this weekend
actually I've traded both ways
something I think about when I've got
nothing else to do watch a loud Bible
videos of course
no joke and then
I'll just have a look and think is that
meant to be over or under
and I've tried both and I think
I think gravity
when it's under gravity pulls it down no
when it's over gravity pulls it down
quicker I find
and just like you pull you all you have
to do is pull a little bit and it all
goes down so I'm a bit of an under guy
these days yeah but I might change this
weekend and try it again okay
what do you most look forward to about
getting old
God
um moving to the countryside
and building a house in a golf course
would you feel more relaxed if you had a
coloring book I would
thank you thank you a golf coloring book
half of these guys look like me by the
way there's like little caricatures of
me
would you mind if I ask you some
questions whilst you color
if you want yeah
[Laughter]
if you're in a bad
refer to be left alone or someone to
cheer you up left alone you don't want
to be around me when I'm in a bad mood
that seems clear
what colors are you going for well it's
a golf coloring boxes there's a lot of
green so I'm just going to start with
I'm gonna start with uh with that for a
second
what's your favorite way to show someone
love
uh
uh words of affirmation
can you give us some examples
I love you baby girl
[Laughter]
leave it at that yeah
that would work yeah see gotcha
do you feel more relaxed with a slice of
pizza
I do like pizza
yeah should we see your coloring yeah
I'm going really far but we're getting
there it's got orange trousers wow
that's really good thank you
thank you
[Applause]
someone literally just got the dominoes
yes
yes oh look at that garlic the garlic
dip from Domino's
[Music]
wait a vanilla person so
Margaret is my way that was nice
a slice of pizza Guinness
a coloring book
a dressing gown
what morning would you rather be outside
running in the pouring rain or laid in
bed wrapped up with the rain outside
laid in bed
all warm watching the rain fall
that's what I did for most of my life
living in Ireland yeah
yeah it's the only option
do you have any recurring dreams
yeah but I don't really want to talk
about it
would you feel more relaxed reading some
poetry yeah I'll I'll try I've got a
strong reading age
[Music]
here we go
I actually had this book at home early
enough I never read it
would you like to hear a stanza
did you like that if you will
flowers on your doorstep
you deserve flowers on your doorstep and
coffee in the morning
you deserve notes left on your dashboard
an ice cream sundaes at 3am
you deserve honesty every day and to be
kissed every hour
you deserve to be reminded how beautiful
you are
and if he let me
I'll show you every day
I promise
namaste
[Music]
is there a thing or person you would be
happy to spend every day with
is there a thing or person
my guitar my golf clubs
my girlfriend
in no particular order because I've
named them very badly well
I'm sorry
no particular order
oh I'm gonna get in trouble
cuddles
my girlfriend
enough golf clubs
would you rather cuddle a kitten or a
puppy a puppy
what do you feel more relaxed if you had
a puppy right now
yeah
shut your mouth
shut up hello
come sit
hello
this is
Peggy look at me come here get around
hello how are you
this
Peggy's got no interest bye Peggy
Peggy wants Guinness
what are you most grateful for
everything
um
all of it the older I've gotten the more
grateful I've become been very lucky in
my life so I am grateful for it all
come on Pig
in your own time bring your awareness
back to the present
we're gonna breathe in again slowly
and breathe out
and let this experience Inspire the rest
of your day
do you feel relaxed yeah too relaxed
let's go and do a full day's work now
yeah but thank you
look at this
mommy's proud of you Peggy
Premier Magus and what this is Scottish
is it yeah I'll have a look up back
cooked lamb lungs you know with oatmeal
and spices it sounds far why does anyone
eat this no offense to him who likes it
obviously what else do they have in
Scotland that they didn't like deep
fried Mars Bars